[Music]
Thomas Alva Edison boys trust you
brought your checkbooks so full of ideas
if it'll taking 12 lifetimes to execute
it I'm working on something now
something so new that the world will
never be the same I'm George
Westinghouse Edison's new electric
system is significantly cheaper than gas
does that keep you up at night there's
always more to see we are gonna be big
Edison says he's months away from
lighting up the world stoves washing
machine electric carriages I could do
the same thing with electricity that I
do with gas Westinghouse Electric
Company Edison Electric it has to be
vultures in every venture got to keep
boy this is what he thinks of you don't
let him agitate you this is how he is
sword Westinghouse Electric shall endure
it's a parasite his current skills
people indeed because you said it was
mr. Edison
if you say something about me or my
company again I would ask that you tell
the truth
Automation transportation communication
that the man that controls that cart
controls that future
though he may be unfamiliar to you his
studies have demonstrated an
understanding of electrical matters
unlike anyone I have ever known
gentlemen and lady Nikola Tesla so
what's your trade I fix problems for
idiots
[Music]